if you're tired of overeating and
binging especially while trying to lose
weight you need to watch this
[Music]
hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's Kitchen in today's video I will
be talking about binge eating overeating
and the most common clinical eating
disorder binge eating disorder or bed
why you're struggling and how to stop a
big thank you to Aaron Davis today for
her expert support on the research Aaron
is one of my recommended RDS for weight
inclusive care so I highly recommend
reaching out if you're looking for some
one-on-one Support also be sure to check
out my disclaimer below as obviously
we're going to be talking about
disordered eating and also you can find
my link to download my free Hunger
crushing combo ebook Okay first I need
to tell you what my sponsor today bio
trust so I've spoken about the emerging
research on collagen a number of times
in the past and the last time we checked
in on this I said that the research is
finally at a point where I'm confident
it's more than just hype we now have
lots of quality data and recent reviews
confirming its use for skin health so
collagen is uniquely rich in
hydroxyproline Proline and glycine which
appears to help with signaling skin cell
proliferation and hyaluronic acid
synthesis both of which can help to
support skin elasticity so in addition
to a balanced very diet I personally
have been incorporating collagen into my
beauty and wellness routine I love
BioTrust ageless multi collagen plus
turmeric powder because it contains a
blend of five different types of
collagen for full body support Beyond
just skin and Joints it specifically has
Type 2 collagen which a lot of collagen
Brands don't have which is the type that
helps to support joint health they also
are really smart and added in the amino
acid tryptophan which together makes
BioTrust blend a uniquely complete
protein and another feature that sets
them apart is the turmeric so turmeric
has powerful antioxidant properties and
supports a healthy inflammatory response
further amplifying the skin joint and
even gut health benefits and honestly
the turmeric based golden milk blend
with cinnamon and ginger in there just
tastes so amazing you can mix it into
hot or cold liquid but I'm partial to
making it into my afternoon pick-me-up
tea so so if you want to check out
BioTrust click the link in my
description to get up to 51 off of your
order plus free shipping along with a
60-day money-back guarantee and thank
you again to BioTrust for sponsoring
this video again don't forget to check
out the link in the description to get
51 off of your first order plus free
shipping and a 60-day money-back
guarantee okay so first of all what is
the difference between overeating and an
actual Ed like binge eating disorder
well first of all everyone overeats on
occasion even like the most seasoned
intuitive eater will occasionally eat
past the point of fullness you know on
like holidays when your aunt's stuffing
looks really really extra good or like
you've got your grandma's and you don't
want to offend her Etc no I I couldn't
have enough
anyone give me one more I'm gonna have
one more and then that'll be it
occasionally eating more calories than
your body needs is ultimately just part
of normal healthy eating in stark
contrast BD is a diagnosable eating
disorder in the DSM-5 that's defined as
episodes of consuming an above normal
amount of food within any two hour
period at least once a day a week for at
least three months and these eating
episodes need to be accompanied by an
overwhelming feeling of a loss of
control where you feel like you cannot
stop the binging episode no matter what
even when you don't meet the DSM
criteria for binging disorder your binge
eating may also be considered disordered
eating because it's interfering with
your quality of life so we're going to
be talking about why you're in the cycle
and what you can do about it so binge
eating is often related to difficulties
in emotional regulation and there are a
number of potential triggers that can
encourage that switch to flip and for us
to use food as our primary or sole way
to cope number one genetics and brain
physiology so I have to touch on this
first because sometimes it's just
reassuring to know that you didn't do
something to cause this like it's very
much how I felt when I got my ADHD
diagnosis like finally I felt like I
could stop gaslighting myself that you
know I was just too sensitive or I was
too weak or too emotional or had poor
willpower Etc so we now know that folks
that have binge eating disorder or
binging Tendencies tend to demonstrate
low serotonin and dopamine levels and
abnormalities in serotonin and dopamine
receptors in the brain since these
neurotransmitters are essentially
involved in the pleasure systems in our
brain folks with chronic deficiencies
may experience greater reward outputs
from pleasure sources like food number
two psychiatric conditions and
neurodiversity so binge eating is
heavily correlated with mood disorders
like depression and anxiety and also
with neurodiversity like ADHD and autism
so I talked about that a little bit in
my ADHD video right here but Risa
suggests that 20 to 30 percent of folks
with ADHD will have an eating disorder
and binge eating is typically the most
common there's likely a brain genetic
component that we talked about but
there's also questions about what comes
first the Ed or the other psych disorder
because often you know food becomes a
way to harness some control or pleasure
or an escape number three is stress and
mood so obviously as we talked about
there's the clinical anxiety disorder
piece but research also suggests that
higher levels of perceived stress has
been shown to result in a desire to
binge in women specifically having a
stressful episode in your day would
significantly increase the risk of a
same-day binge we're having good social
support could help decrease it number
four is is perfectionism so a very
common psychiatric comorbidity is bed
and ocpd AKA obsessive compulsive
personality disorder which is basically
grounded in this idea of perfectionism
and there are a number of different
types of perfectionists but Theresa
suggests that the most at risk for
binging are those that are particularly
concerned by others approval or
criticism binge eating is often used to
escape feelings of loneliness or failure
or sadness or the discouraging and
critical reality that a perfectionist
faces every single day and to do that
you basically need to set aside higher
order thought and really ground yourself
in something visceral and immediate and
the experience of eating something
delicious you know the smelling and the
chewing and the tasting this is a primal
way for a perfectionist to find that
escape I'm actually working on a whole
video on perfectionism as it pertains to
your diet so if you're interested in
learning more definitely leave me a
comment below if you can relate number
five is the gut microbiome so this is
really interesting to me but basically
the gut microbiome is often thought of
as the second brain and we now have a
lot of emerging studies suggesting that
imbalances in gut Flora may be
associated with binge eating and obesity
so for example one study found that a
decrease in specific bacteria species
like acromancia and intestimona species
and an increase in bifidobacterium
anrostites I think it's called aneral
stapes these were associated with binge
eating disorder and this is all leading
to a whole emerging field of using
probiotics as a potential treatment for
eating disorders and if you stick around
I will tell you exactly what strain to
look for number six family upbringing
and attitudes around food so obviously
childhood trauma and abuse is associated
with binge eating because again as you
can imagine food becomes a much needed
escape and there are other potential
psychosocial triggers for binge eating
including physical and sexual abuse and
discrimination but to focus for a moment
on childhood and parental upbringing we
know that parental attitudes and
behaviors around eating can play a
significant role so outside of the
context of neurodiversity or other
pathologies healthy children are
ultimately born intuitive eaters they
know when they're hungry and they know
when they're full and countless studies
now have looked at the risk factors for
eating in the absence of hunger and how
that in turn can increase the risk of
overeating binge eating and obesity in
adolescence and adulthood so as you can
imagine diet restriction in early
childhood tends to increase the
likelihood that older children and
adults will overeat when they get the
chance I mean this to me is just basic
evolutionary human nature right we've
been conditioned to not be fed when
we're hungry then when we finally do get
access we're gonna over it and this
isn't just about food quantity in cases
of food insecurity where one city found
that food insecurity increased the risk
of binging by 40 percent but we're also
talking about food quality and variety
and this is really why I so often talk
about the problems with the Almond mom
Trope right restricting our kids so
aggressively will always backfire and
cause the opposite of intended effects
kids who are put on diets end up
significantly at a higher risk of
obesity binge eating dieting unhealthy
eating behaviors and poor body image
years later so yeah this is a kind of
Biggie for me because I feel that it's
one that we so easily can avoid with the
Next Generation another potentially
avoidable or modifiable factor is social
media use and this is really not
surprising and it's definitely one of
the reasons why I do what I do here but
one recent review at the literature
found that social media use was directly
or indirectly associated with binge
eating the more participants use social
media the more likely they would have
increased intentions to eat and binge
and this may have to do with social
comparison constant body surveillance
through non-stop video creation and the
proliferation of misinformation on
social media apps I mean again this is
exactly why I do what I'm doing right
now and it would require a whole video
for me to fully unpack so definitely let
me know in the comments if that's of
interest to you but I really think it's
no secret that Tick Tock is not good for
anyone's mind or body for that matter
not that I want you to not follow me or
watch my videos but honestly if this
were all to disappear I wouldn't be mad
and then finally we of course need to
talk about restriction and dieting you
guys knew I wasn't going to skip this
one so research consistently suggests
that restriction or dieting is one of
the greatest predictors of a binge
dieters are two to three times more
likely than non-dieters to develop binge
eating habits within five years if you
guys are a regular here on Abby's
kitchen you've probably heard me talk
about the binge restrict cycle basically
you go on a diet AKA you restrict which
then leads you to obsess over food or
what you're no longer allowed to have
then when you get a moment of
opportunity just a little taster you
can't help yourself but to binge and
overeat like the floodgates are open and
you can barely get your fill and this of
course then leads to feelings of guilt
and shame which brings you right back to
the Restriction rinse repeat rinse
repeat
I'm not going to stop the wheel
I'm going to break the wheel
obviously not everyone who goes on a
diet will end up with a binge eating
disorder but in addition to how strict
your diet is it does seem that having
feelings of depression or low
self-esteem are particularly Salient
factors in driving up the risk so
hopefully now
reasons why you binge but
they're thinking what the do I do
about it now obviously what strategy is
really going to move the needle for you
may depend on your why but I want to
share with you some evidence-based
recommendations and tips that are used
every day in clinical settings with
dietitians and therapy teens so step
number one Journal your food and binging
episodes so you can just do this in a
basic line journal or there are a lot of
great mindful eating journals that you
can buy like this one that I saw on Etsy
but I want you to journal what you ate
when you ate where you were your hunger
levels how satisfied you felt afterwards
and how it affected your mood you don't
need to be specific like you would if
you were like tracking calories we don't
need to know specifics of exactly how
much oil you added or any kind of
calorie counting or anything like that
but I want you to take notice of how
satisfied you're allowing yourself to be
how hungry did you let yourself get
before eating how full were you when you
stopped are there particular foods that
you're obsessing over or particularly
tempted to overeat notice that these
episodes are accompanied by other
non-food triggers so like a fight or a
stressful day at work or really bad news
or a specific place or person and I also
want you to take note of how soon you're
thinking about food again between meals
as we've established binging triggers
are highly individualized but
understanding your personal patterns is
the first step to fixing them so now
you've got some data let's talk about
ways to incorporate acts of self-care
that can downplay some of these triggers
scenario number one you're binging on
specific Foods or food groups like carbs
the solution habituate habituate
habituate this is probably going to be
the most difficult piece of advice that
I give here but also probably the most
important for the most amount of people
if we continue to put food on a pedestal
so far Out Of Reach we are going to
obsess like it's human nature to want to
seek out the forbidden fruit so don't
make it forbidden anymore and this is
the whole Crux of my video series on
turning fear Foods into hunger crushing
combos like I talked about how when I
was struggling with my eating disorder I
would binge on cereal it was a bad food
in my mind so I made the choice to eat
cereal every day as part of my recovery
first there's like a handful then it was
a bowl and then eventually just became
another food that I could comfortably
pair with other foods to make it more
satiating AKA I could put my lucky
charms on like some Greek yogurt with
some fruit and call it a balanced meal
if you want to stop the bench restrict
cycle you have to nip it in the bud here
not here so for those of you guys who
are trying to lose weight I hear you
you're thinking well then I will never
see improvements on the scale but in
response I would ask what is the point
of losing and gaining the same five to
ten pounds because you're restricting
too hard too fast so this might mean
having a slower more realistic weight
loss goal and also finding ways to
incorporate the foods that you really
love into your daily plan so I
definitely recommend re-watching my fear
food series because it will give you
some ideas on how to eat nutrient-dense
meals that can still support weight loss
without pulling the reins so tight you
eventually binge scenario number two you
binge when you let yourself get too
hungry before a meal so the solution
here very common I want you to set an
alarm on your phone to eat every two to
three hours having a solid structure in
your routine can really help to
alleviate the chaotic nature of the
binge because you can be confident that
you will be fed very soon scenario
number three you binge when you're over
tired or overworked now an obvious
solution to this would just be to make a
priority to start your bedtime routine
earlier so that you can get a better
sleep and there are so many reasons why
sleep is important for overall health
but also for appetite management
scenario number four you notice that
there are specific places or people that
trigger a binge so let's say that you
always overeat when you're with your
in-laws in this case I want you to ask
yourself how can you be more prepared
maybe this means having a solid hunger
crushing combo snack before you go or
rehearsing responses for if your family
pressures you to eat more so now five
you're triggered by social media content
online always a good idea to do like a
monthly feed detox to remove any
triggering accounts or content creators
from your feed that you do not feel
support your goals you can also set
self-care boundaries for yourself for
when you can go on your apps and when
you can't that's definitely something
that has helped me a lot in my Journeys
scenario number six your binges line up
with particularly stressful moments so
this for me is about finding time to
explore other non-food coping strategies
mindfulness practices and meditation
have been shown to help reduce binge
eating episodes but you can also
consider other non-food coping
strategies like going for a walk or
talking to a friend or window shopping
baking reading swimming or any other
pleasurable act or hobby that can help
to diffuse the urgency to binge
and finally maybe your binges seem to be
related to a mental health or
neurodivergency related episode so the
solution here is obviously not a quick
fix but seeking supports for those
conditions should be your priority so
cognitive behavioral therapy and
interpersonal Psychotherapy have been
proven effective at treating binge
eating disorder and the medication
Vyvanse which is also used for ADHD has
also been approved specifically for
binge eating I also mentioned earlier
that probiotic therapy is currently
being studied and I'm really
particularly excited about this and we
do have some early research that
suggests that supplementing with
lactobacillus rhamnosis probiotic may
help to reduce binge eating Tendencies
so as I said the solution to binge
eating is never going to be black or
white or stagnant it's going to be
likely a journey and one that is highly
individualized so I do encourage you to
seek out professional support when you
can again I'm going to leave a link to
Aaron's website site below but I would
love to hear from you guys about what
has helped you with your binge eating
Tendencies whether in the past or
currently so if you're up to it please
leave a comment below and on that note I
gotta cook some pancakes if you guys
like this video be sure to give it the
thumbs up don't forget to hit that
subscribe button and hit my description
for my free Hunger crushing combo ebook
and I'll see you next time on Abby's
kitchen bye
[Music]